this is a production of Cornell
University
so and what I put together is I guess
it's a trends talk I piece together
things that either we know that are
going on out there in the business
because we have seen some problem with
it from a company perspective or it's
things that we're picking up in the
industry some of it is things that I did
a little research them just like you
guys actually did all the research work
and put some things together so I feel
like I'm giving my oral report this
afternoon and and some of it comes from
some things that we picked up from some
of the trade shows and some of our
programs and so forth it's just kind of
a collective what's going on out there
and you know what where is the director
going as it relates to 'pliance and so
forth so I just pieced it together I
have not delivered this to anybody yet
so you guys are truly marketing pics and
since it's a nice intimate audience I
don't think if you've got questions or
hope you have questions or comments and
support we can make this more of a
discussion along the way to as well but
anyway so I just be some stuff together
we are as a company we are involved in
product development we are a plant
breeder we also produce the Harlem
genetics now we are principally in the
flowering ornamentals part of the
business lots of flowering annuals that
we create and then produce starting
either seat for more vegetatively
propagated material but we have as of
late to go into venture more into
vegetables as well since we watched the
home garden vegetable crate start to
kick in a few years ago before the
recession that has continued to kick in
and also have branched out not to use
too many funds to get into ornamental
shrubs to as well
to better serve the the true nursery
part of the business in addition to our
greenhouse customers so that's that's us
as plant breeder we're also a wholesale
distributors what we call ourselves were
broker to as well selling our own
genetics seen in young plants to
greenhouse growers of all sizes
throughout the country and handed up
north america as well as we have
distribution companies in various
markets around the world and do the same
thing and we try to be a full-service
sales organization of broker to our
customers we sell our own genetics but
we also sell all of the other seed
companies in other plant breeders
genetics to as well so that's we can be
kind of a one-stop shop so that's a
little bit of the structure of the
business we're based in far west
suburban Chicago Illinois where it looks
more or less like this although you guys
first coat of snow and and we just get
rid of ours home bases in Chicago we
have distribution in Western Europe we
also have reading division facility up
in a housing in Holland as well as the
distribution in Western Europe we are
also in China with production we are in
Japan Korea Australia South Africa and
then throughout central South America in
distribution as well as our production
most of our production is done at
Central America to as well but we're
really the North American based business
subsidiaries around the world and it's
because it's a world market as you guys
know
so anyway a little bit about us as Bell
said I'm the HR guy with ball i joined
ball 11 years ago I had no plant
background I was a lousy science student
I have a business degree and I spent
about 20 years or so in the retail
industry working for various department
store companies and so forth and it was
fun had a great time as I said you know
what it's kind of time to do something
else and I'm all they were down the
street from me and I've spent the last
11 years learning about the plant
business both the side side as well as
the commercial side which is great
because my wife never bought a big
backyard gardeners we have no lawn in
the backyard I'm very proud to say it's
all garden so it could be much less to
have to mow all right what I put
together um it's a collection of things
that that again from from things that
we've heard about that are going on out
there in the industry from some research
that I did and so forth and so I thought
I'd start out with this is is there's
this little quote we have a plant
breeder actually she's our most senior
played four yards she's kind of coined
it this way she keeps talking about this
new relationship between plants and
people in other words I'm direction
where we think the industry is going and
the illustration by the way I threw it
on their purpose there is a professor at
Columbia University by the last name
despo me a homer person is Dixon and he
published a book last year on this
concept of urban vertical farming the
idea being is the populations around the
major metropolitan centers around the
world continue to grow and it was pretty
many places like Tokyo and Seoul and
other great large cities where from a
residential standpoint
but he lives up because there's very
little land mass in the idea with
farming as it really particular as it
relates to sustainability and so forth
is how do we get the crops closer to
where the population is rather than
having to truck so far away and so forth
so he broke is this book about the
concept of putting together
sophisticated vertical farming systems
kind of a pipe dream but it is being
talked about a lot because a lot of the
technologies are already there already
in place it's just a matter of can
something like this happen so it's kind
of a big picture thing to kind of kick
off all right here's where I did my
research I went online Google gardening
trends 2011 and this is what i found and
i found like three or four different
offers writing about these kinds of
things and they all use literally the
same terms so they're either you know
emailing to each other all the time but
they're all kind of picking up on some
of the same trends and this is what i
felt gardening with a purpose these are
all phrases that literally the people
wrote about urban farming aquascaping
sustainability of course are we talked
about all the time new urbanism vertical
gardening a lot ornamental singles on
and on it or not so I thought well how
are these all trends and if you take a
look at people when you guys see these
what comes to mind which once you're
actually you see these kinds of phrases
I'm really asking you what comes to mind
seems seems very small-scale oriented so
that it's a market it's not the business
driven Kate's target market that's true
that's right that's right what else
it is a trend tried to take people that
are could be there clean absolutely you
get the sense that it's more personal
and it took place it relates to things
like urban bar being organism vertical
gardening gardening what the purpose is
so forth but it was interesting that I
found different authors all writing
about the same thing so I thought what
cable was less fun sometimes kind of
going through these first there was and
what I try to do is replace to these we
kind of illustrate if these are friends
are not is I went looking for examples
of each of these and that's actually the
rest of what these slides are all
focusing because I found examples of
virtually no stuff that's going on there
was a trade show and education program
in the brand name is a second-wicket
january it's a national association
called the western nursery and landscape
associations been around parenting roles
200 covers both United States and Canada
it's it's an interesting mix of
professionals its greenhouse growers its
garden centers this landscape architects
Landscape Contractors and other people
that are other parts of the green at
district so it's not just a grower group
that's pretty broad group and they had
this seminar program in January my boss
attended a couple of other people to two
and one of these is they really try to
make this this education program a bit
different on the technical trade show
and so one things they did is they put
together a panel discussion and so they
had a try think oh my boss is one of
them that they had a landscape architect
a professor a fairly well-known
reasonable garden center owner you know
kind of a mix of people and they went up
and they talked about where they think
horticultural regarding is going to be
in the year 2060 in other words about
years ago and so I just pulled some some
notes from from what they had to say and
on the rate of tickets are low hard to
read they were talking about things like
plants will move to where they serve
your purpose not just serve people
plants will build from providing beauty
actually working in other words being
used as part of the system landscapes
will be green machines living machines
and landscapers will be the Machinists
putting the machines to go what they
talked about the concept of rather than
thinking ourselves as consumers what we
thought of yourselves as citizens kind
of changes the equation of all that
changes the mindset a little bit and
people be growing plants for air / air
purification rain collection cooling
eating water retention Oh yawn also may
be renewed exhibit as well so it's you
know pretty profound thinking going into
the future so a completely different
approach to the whole idea of using
plants this is Patricia so gardening
with a purpose all right here's some
examples gardening used as the backdrop
for educational programs we're seeing
more and more of this between several of
us actually where I work I'll get an
email or a phone call from time to time
another couple the company will too
they're constantly asking us if we can
provide educational resources for people
that are doing gardening programs
whether it's schools or parks or
community organizations and so forth and
so one of the things that we've done to
try to help out is we have we've
launched a brand in the past couple of
years actually last year was the first
year starting with going after the home
gardening no home vegetable gardening
the customer under the banner her be
home garden
licensing the bourbonnais and as part of
the effort is we're putting a lot of PR
into vertical gardens by using as the
vehicle to put together some educational
program in fact a little risk recently
did for the first time as we held a
grand contest and we collaborated with
the nation of gardening Association and
put out this contest we got over it was
almost 250 applications from all around
the country a whole bunch of is
evaluated at all we literally correct
one after another and to try to
prioritize them and awarded five of them
they're all getting a pretty big prize
to help them with their gardening
education programs so we really see that
proliferating whether its youth
gardening or adult guarding and not just
teaching the gardening but using the
gardening to teach people various
science topics math even english and
literature in terms of writing and also
some of the business and marketing
skills to as well from from harvesting
to as well community gardens are
proliferating a lot of areas csas you
know the community sponsored agriculture
or the idea that people in a community
will pay a farmer in advance of the
season for our seasons worth of produce
so that way you get a harvest throughout
the season and the farmer gets funds up
front to do the production farmers
markets I don't know if you guys have
any around here enjoy yer yeah but
they're proliferating in the penal kinds
of communities so let's just just want
it one set of examples second one
related to urban farming and i found
this was pretty interesting this is a
wall of tomatoes in fact it's a variety
of two males a candle suit uses for its
famous tomato soup and their big Blanche
they try to help out the community is a
lot of different place and they put
together this urban gardening program
this was in Harlem both to obviously get
education out but also be able to allow
production and harvest to serve the
local community and there's a couple of
other organizations are confirming
downward and then another organizations
done similar types of things in LA and
harlem and so forth and they're trying
to get tired trying to take advantage of
what space is available in some of the
urban cities to put together farming
systems small farming systems and plots
of land to provide food for that local
community and also taking advantage of
technology allowing for vertical growing
so it's you know that it's this dis
bobbing thing but on a much smaller
scale it's one way to think about it and
it's actually going out there this is
grant park in the downtown of the city
of Chicago grant park is the big Park
area along the lake right in the center
of downtown there's a small farm I guess
you call it a garden area it's all a
combination of vegetables herbs and
flowering plants similar kind of program
there's an organization called growing
power it's a not-for-profit and they
work with both the landscaper as well as
the city parks department and put
together this garden and it's a show
garden but they also actually harvest
from the garden and again it goes to
local farmer local farmers markets be
sold as local produce around the city
but they also use it again as an
education format to they take students
and teach them planting weeding
harvesting so they get a chance to see
the whole cycle for the season and also
they're responsible for helping package
and process the fruit vegetables
nerds and so forth and actually sell
them in the farmers market so they also
teach in customer service skills and
sales skills marketing skills and so
forth so it's more than just a garden
and the same thing here with a second
farm that's literally on a plot of land
near south side to help people in that
community I learn how to grow their own
vegetables and harvest our own
vegetables so these are kind of summer
electric samples
I'm through this on here because I was a
week ago yesterday I was reading Sunday
newspapers that I used in New York Times
and there was this article about this
guy was an ex-marine he's a have a cop
about Cabo farmer in San Diego has to be
an organic avocado farmer who's an
avocado farmer and tina's wife in the
last several years have put together a
program to teach returning veterans how
to farm international educational
programming they've hooked up with a
local college and so they put the whole
thing together and they teach returning
veterans the whole process of farming
because whether it's the AG department
or its other associations and so they're
all talking about the fact in the next
ten years half of America's farmers are
retired and there isn't the next
generation necessarily coming in behind
them they stun the numbers that we need
so it gives it the veterans a chance to
learn a trade as they come back from
wherever they've been in service it's
also especially for returning veterans
it's fun is therapeutic in a way because
they're doing something very positive
very constructive after my own
experiences they've just been especially
if they serve it from lines overseas and
anytime is a pretty good program flow is
pretty cool they also mentioned the
article that there's a couple
universities including University
nebraska's doing the same thing through
the rank college specifically targeted
to
alright another one echo skating I
couldn't tell you a few years ago for
you ever heard the term rain garden but
now it's becoming very popular and you
find rain barrels at garden centers and
Home Depot everywhere else people are
really starting to pay attention to how
to better utilize resources whether it
be water obviously chemicals and
fertilizers and so forth but also even
as it relates to take care of your own
property people are starting to take a
look at these expanses of one that we
traditionally have had instinct there's
better ways to use the land both terms
of aesthetics but also in terms of just
cutting down the use of all the energy
that you have to put into and
maintaining lon so that's I think that's
what they mean by the aquascape so it's
things like putting together more
sustainable types of gardens in your
yard using less chemicals and so forth
these are a couple of examples of things
that we're working on with either
compostable or completely biodegradable
packaging containers this container we
have been working on for a few years to
try to perfect this is a resin but it is
completely biodegradable you can plant
the plant in the pot in the ground and
it would all go into the land breakdown
same thing with this which is literally
just a paper wrap with no bottom it's
it's called a soilless wrap we're trying
to perfect this so we can make it
commercial it would discovered how we
can also print on it too so not only is
it biodegradable so for the consumer the
landscaper they literally just take the
plant put it right into the ground
saving both the waste as well as the
labor and expense of you
way all the pots and containers but we
can also educated consumer by what we've
put on to as well to help them and make
it easier to buy plant so these are all
different kinds of things that are going
on in the industry as a place to being
more eco-friendly a couple more examples
this was something I picked up southern
nevada water authority this is a vegas
las vegas home they got a rebate for
replacing their 2,200 square feet of
lawn with water efficient plants so
literally communities paying citizens
for doing something different than
playing them along this example so we
have things that look more like this
some different examples you have you
guys heard of the acronym lead led okay
good are you there is a engineering
company in New York that did a retrofit
of their existing building not a new
building but they didn't retrofit and
then filed the application to get LEED
certification for it and they were the
first ones I think it happened but
technically happen to those naughty but
they were the personal asst to get
awarded lead credit for plant use as
part of their retrofit this is the
interior and it's part of the exterior
so a whole idea of leads which is you
know more sustainable you building use
both in terms of materials as well as
the environment you're creating building
and so forth is now being extended to
the use of plants too as well so it's
another way of plans its function as
opposed to plants just as he hasn't
missed it anyway this is Chicago it's
the rooftop of City Hall and that this
has actually been here for several years
it's it's it's an experiment but it's a
way to figure out old large energy
consuming buildings and do systems like
this help at least both with temperature
control and those types of things so
another example and I found these just
by poking around a bit again this idea
of going vertical even if it's just for
looks so forth
just a concrete wall you know much nicer
and you can see in these urban spaces
more and more income that's my favorite
okay I'm from Chicago you guys can tell
this is a shot looking north of Michigan
Avenue several years ago looks like
typical cityscape and this is what it
looks like today these these bunkers I'm
really sure what they call that have
been placed installed over the last
couple years up and down Michigan Avenue
along River Road on both sides of the
river and so forth again and as you can
tell from the plantings really planted
combination of subtropical lots of
trailing material annuals perennials
ornamental shrubs and so forth and the
whole idea is it is for tourism that to
help you know the city look more
attractive for visitors is so forth but
what the city's finding is it also
provides lots of other advantages too as
well and other cities are finding the
same thing it helps create a different
kind of environment which in essence
those things like it obviously makes an
improvement in property values it
actually has an impact on crime because
of a blighted areas blighted it looks
it's more of an invitation for criminal
activity if it's not blinded it looks
like you know
more safe place in there four you don't
have as many problems so again using
plants for other purposes of an interest
beauty does the city have real numbers
on that because I believe all of that
but that's always the limiting I know
this because I all believe that I great
i agree i hope i hope there's I don't
know I don't know though I don't know if
Chicago no of the city has I know that
there have been research studies that
have tried to quantify some of this so
they are out there but and that is one
of the challenges is how to tailgate the
more quantifiable information about how
these types of landscapes and the use
for them so forth actually has value
because if we can can quantify it born I
think that would make this an even
stronger trend I'm able to be in the
development further
okay so that's one part so we talked
about the grower a little bit these are
gain are some some additional quotes
from that panel from the green center
program that ran in st. Louis last one
that I mentioned about earlier because
they also were talking about as it
relates to where the industry is going
from a from a consumer perspective and a
grower perspective and some of the
growers were talk about the fact that in
the future they believe that plants
would be manipulated they use the word
manipulated not just by genetics
somebody wants me but also how they're
grown and I can tell you as a plant
breeder that's a pretty profound
statement because we're very proud of
ourselves in terms of creating a new
product because we go through all the
research in the effort to figure out how
the product going to perform how should
it be positioned in the marketplace
whether it's a what purpose it would
best serve what kind of containers
should be started in how should be sold
in the stores and so forth as a plant
breeder we try to do all that work so
that we can get the product in the
marketplace and the groceries that
growers are saying yeah that's all fine
but we've got even more important
challenges at our end of the stage and
we've got to be able to produce plants
then meet the very specific needs of
whether it's a landscaper or is the
retailer than ultimate consumer so they
see even more influence as it relates to
how plants are grown and how they're
used being put on for over two as well
concept of on-demand plants in other
words wanting supply of plants 12 months
a year even though it's a seasonal
business they see Adam and can grow to
wear for whatever the purposes are going
from you
might be is it might be more of a
year-round business another one for the
grower this plants need to be
programmable for retail promotion if I'm
a supplier to loads or a home depot or
walmart and so forth and if I put
together a Sunday flyer that promotes
XYZ product and I that flyer covers on
200 stores let's say well that plant has
to be in that story good performance
that Sunday in those 200 stores that's
what they mean by programmable and
that's what the growers got to figure
out how do I get that volume plans to be
ready for delivery
gardeners themselves they think
especially young guard is the next
generation also want program
programmable plants in other words they
want plans to do specific things and
they want that instant color and so
forth we're no longer with the
generation that's willing to get down on
their hands and knees early in the
spring plant pots of beds likewise
plants and knowing that they're not
really going to get the result until
July no the summer give or take people
want kind of instant gratification when
they go out and buy plants then the
different concept is is talking about
the fact that they see that retailers
may become smaller and more local even
the big box stores possible which is
kind of an interesting concept I work
for home people for a couple of years
back in the late 90s and we were talking
about or they were talking about small
store formats back then particularly as
spill in stores the larger communities
where there are already existing stores
if you build one more big story you
start to cannibalize in the sales from
the other stores in the chains of tried
I think different approaches but this
might more relate to the whole idea of
doing things more locally might be where
this constant
okay another topic sustainability guys
are all familiar with more existing I
know right one of the things that I know
is probably coming is there's already
been some effort is the idea trying to
develop more uniform standards I guess
the best way to describe it in terms of
you know how do we measure or whether or
not a product is sustainable and what's
the definition of sustainability and in
terms of its purpose and uses so forth
in fact the one of my colleagues at work
had been involved with an effort
nationwide a broad effort with a number
of different agriculture industries
represented to try to put together a set
of standards and the challenges is
because there are so many different
agendas if you will Rick being
represented by different parts of the
agriculture industry it's hard to come
together with a common set of standards
so far we haven't been successful but
I'm assuming at some point that it's
coming and as soon as we get to both the
idea of quantifying more in terms of how
plants can perform and how think they
can be used as well as a more sustained
sustainable set of standards I think
that we're really accelerate this whole
idea of converting from chemical use and
so forth too much more sustainable
practices as far
because that's my sense is where it's
going home so think about it this way
you're in a greenhouse running
greenhouse operation and everything you
do ends up being public information all
completely transparent changes a lot of
what you think about in terms of how you
manage your greenhouse production today
this is what food companies deal with
you guys have recognized this it's
almost on every boxed and canned food
item in America listing all the
ingredients calories etc etc etc so what
would happen if we did the same thing
now suddenly if we come up with a set of
standards that's how we're going to get
measured and the idea behind trying to
come up with our own standards is if we
can come up with them so that they're
workable for growers for producers
that's probably far better than it at
some point they get legislative and get
four stars so it's it's an effort that's
still in front of us but I think it's
going
okay consumer so where do we think the
consumer is going well one thing I
mentioned a little bit earlier is this
whether it's a trend or fad but home
garden vegetables became popular again a
few years ago and actually a few years
before the recession hit and then with
with the recession because of the
emphasis on spending less money and so
forth there soon be even more interest
in the idea of growing the realm it's
become even more popular so it looks
like it's a trend that's going to stay
here for a while although the rate of
growth in sales and home garden
vegetables is starting to level off a
little bit I don't think it's going to
go away i think that interest is there
because i think it's converging with
with other more social interests about
whether it's again and any idea but
using vegetables there to have a
community garden or it's because you
want to feel like you're doing things
more sustainably for your own backyard
and whatever it might be I think
vegetable garden is here to stay and not
just vegetables for all forms of
vegetables herbs are popular again and
partly because of this renewed interest
in cooking you can't turn on TV without
watching some cooking program
oreo report the opening of the magazine
are seeing something online so it's kind
of a natural extension of the cooking
crisis is people interested in growing
their own and also fruits and berries
too not just conscious vegetables that's
just true listener this is a kind
something we came up with and we're
trying to see if there's interest in
this this is there's actually three
seeds in this planet three pellets more
fashion what we've tried to do is put
together a multi multi specie different
types of lettuce all Pelt together in
one pellet and that way you can direct
so it into a container like this curl it
out and have literally in a container
the harvest at less to three times what
if I begins to give out and this is a
commercial product just try to see you
know what different kinds of things
vegetables
also related to a home gardening and
vegetables and so forth you wishin alee
think about the backyard garden where
you've got this rectangular plot the
rows of beans and corn and so forth meds
and flowers or finding is the consumer
Schimmel almost doesn't care anymore
just kind of mixes it all up vegetables
and flowers together vegetables in the
front of the yard not just to the back
of the yard vegetables as ornamentals
not just for for our visit and so forth
so you know we in the industry are still
very traditionally thinking and yet the
consumers just you know finding ways to
putting all different kinds of plans
together and using them different ways
it's even more advanced than we are
actually at some place so as I'm saying
and we've got parsley and fancy it's a
picture I actually found and you know we
talk about things being annuals tropical
things being seed vs vegetative is it a
perennial as a blade you know these are
these are all these are all how we think
about it but you know here's a corollary
you know is this a phone is it a GPS is
it a game player is it an end music
player for the consumer they almost
don't care the idea is opportunity to
bundle things together for in uses that
that makes sense but for the consumer so
we got to put our sometimes butter my
son ahead
consumer as impulsive as a grower so we
better understand where their consumer
my family hello our team we keep talking
about how things are very traditional
approach talking about things and
segregation whereas the consumer thinks
complete integration so how does a big
company like that I know when you're
marketing this type of idea where does
it fall and like a plan patent type of
categories because these I mean making a
little mix of people are doing all the
time but like how do you sell that when
you come up with an idea come on things
like the city six down oh yeah any are
mentioning that take my view of a
combination like it really depends on
it's a relates to pursue Plant
Protection depends on how important it
is you think it is to a dinner protect
the plants not everything is you exactly
is sometimes it's if you can get
products out in a combination like this
and if it takes off it's okay if
somebody else copies it to be there in
all your salty you've got to play get
played situation a little bit
differently
okay the same x relates to the consumer
shopping at the local garden center or
one of the change and so forth it's
still very very difficult for the
average consumer who was not a well
educated if you will Gardner still
getting making it very difficult these
are actual quotes my boss has a plot of
land and next to her residence where
there's no house on it and she decide to
kind of open it up as a community garden
and literally the neighbors come around
and they all have their plotnick plant
vegetables and flowers experience so
forth and she was in a conversation with
one of Monday so literally what pushes
that assessment you guys continue to
think we know a lot more than we do it's
still very very difficult very
intimidating to walk into a garden
center and try to figure out what to ask
what kind of shop and so forth then this
is a quote that one of our folks we
talked about last year we were talking
about the same challenge said you know
my friend going into a garden center has
felt the same experiences my grandmother
trying to go to invest by very very
difficult very challenging so we got to
make it easier cuz gardening for the
average consumer is not intuitive and we
really had to help her put things to go
gotta make a simpler
there's no
again not everybody wanting to get down
on hands and knees but all the upper end
up from the season and one instant it's
the product is gratification instant
color so you know one thing's we're
trying to take advantage of us it's a
lot of people are doing is taking
advantage of electronic communication in
all different ways we finally have
starting to get into the whole bandwagon
of getting on Twitter Facebook and all
those other kinds of things and
companies are doing what we're trying to
do it in different ways the one of the
big advantages of using different forms
of social media is from an advertising
standpoint to an uneven advertising
advertising you decide to go after some
customer your target as you refer to it
and you plaster all your advertising and
whatever form it comes in appointed
director at that person whereas you know
that when the advantage of different
forms of social media it becomes a
two-way conversation commissioning your
bathroom that's you actually care how to
dial okay back and forth so we're trying
to learn how to do that so an example
again what Matt to her be home gardens
as we put together this thing called the
Derby garden coach that you can load
onto your smartphone and
we'll help you shop will help you keep
track of your purchases will give you
planting tips will give you email our
text reminders however however why you
want to receive the information
throughout the season but how you know
how things are going with with your
regard performance and harvest and so
forth the whole idea is to create kind
of a interchange with with the consumer
another way this is going after the
retailer's putting together on this is
all online all the promotional materials
that a garden store may want to use it
helping promote the way product that
they might be selling this our way of
being our portray opportunity again its
interactive rather than just shoving a
bunch of stuff out to a retailer make it
all available and they can pick and
choose what they want
and then this is going after the grower
kind of another form of taking advantage
of the technology is we have these one
to two minutes quick videos literally
using a flip camera on culture tips and
those types of things directly directly
to run for our customers to help them as
they're growing out various genetic
screenplay our stuff so anyway I don't
know if this is really a new era coming
but if you get it you know you read how
some of the things that are going on out
there particularly as it relates to
community efforts whether it gets for
education it's it's for the sociability
of getting communities together is the
interest in gardening it's the interest
in in maybe doing something other than
having a green grass lawn and so forth
these all might be things are kind of
converging together maybe well we are
headed towards kind of the next
generation of healthy people use plants
and today generally if you think about
the whole concept of gardening is all
for beauty its offering aesthetics it's
all for the looks it's a hobby but what
it might be heading towards is
landscaping for what was referred to as
the 3ds one is an economic impact again
some of the examples are solved for some
of the urban areas a second one being
environmental impact kind of the social
consciousness part of where we might be
heading but under the emotional impact
as well but there is this intrinsic
connection that people have with other
living things including plants it maybe
that's part of the reason we're funding
this different connection going but for
all these things that you may refer to
its friends choice after members
whenever you see something happening is
becoming a trend becoming kind of
mainstream is always a triangle in the
opposite direction or if not the
abstract I'm very different direction
coverage and so the other thing I
remember is is everything you think you
know it's probably wrong it's going to
changing it and it's one of the exciting
things and the reason why I put some of
the stuff together for you guys is these
are trends as we see them happening
today and some of the stuff that I have
on here is similar to some things we
were sharing and talks last year so in
other words and you really do see some
of these things as trends but for you I
think what it means is you get a whole
world of challenges and opportunities
out there particularly if the direction
continues to go where people are more
interested whether it's socially or
environmentally and so forth of using
plants as part of lifestyle even more so
past supposed I think those are
opportunities for you so it again my
clothes is is is you got to keep looking
around the corner because you know which
I do okay that's it it's all I got
so some question quite well comments
tomatoes you guys are really going to
producers with resellers just like that
position like the market and you're
talking about the trends like community
garden like how does balls ourselves
were reaching out to those types of
people because right now that's not new
yeah knowing you're right now you guys
don't like the technology to grow the
green walls for them to sell like
retailers to sell or no we know is we
women not but at the same time it helps
us in understanding of how the consumers
you interested in using plants and
Sophie if what we need to work on our
weather specific varieties of vegetables
or whatever it might be whether the plan
is to perform in these ways them then
that tells us what we need to be working
on from a breeding direction the idea if
Myrtle Garth vertical gardening really
does take off and it's possible than it
would have will in certain areas of
whether it's because of lack of land
space or whatever that the reason to
might be then we've got one of things we
should be working on our plant products
have performed well vertically so that's
how it helps us it has a relates to
things like community gardens and
gardening education and so forth it's a
way to help convey to us that the idea
of of gardening's may be coming back
from what it was back in the 80s and 90s
but in a very different form or form
differ different purpose but it still
means that people are going to want to
have plants that perform in that kind of
garden if you think about a community
garden or community garden is probably
set up with pretty lousy irrigation
because you never spend a whole lot
on a bigger piece of property to set up
a community garden it's going to be with
you know whoever going to hook up the
hose nearby so you've got to be able to
create products that sustain themselves
well in those kinds of environment so it
helps establish you as well so that's
what we pay attention to these kinds of
trends and you're right we don't sell to
consumers directly we never will we sell
to the supplier to the retailer who sent
us to the customer but ultimately what
we produce is a product you know I buy
in the store so we have to know what you
want we have to know what you what you
want and what you want to use it for
both of those could you speak a little
more on the that idea that the plants
are going to be chosen i'll include egg
bagel
is that idea talking more of the urban
setting or set more towards the we need
them on that programmable cycle where
you want your poinsettia or your black
friday honestly I think both of what
you're suggesting I there's part but
it's certainly the program from the idea
of hitting retail commissions
particularly for the change and I keep
pointing to the change because that's
where a lot of volume is driven but but
I think it also has to do with with how
people want to use plans to as well is
we might be coming up with a great
something on that trailer thinker or
something like that but we just think is
the greatest thing since sliced bread
but what we may not really realize is
how that product is actually being used
if there's some interest whereas the
growers a bit closer than we are Brazil
they're supplying with retailer might
understand a little better and figure
out how they can grow so that it meets
whether it's either specifications about
how sits on a retail shelf or alter the
weapon consumers looking for to as well
so I think it's both of us
what else good questions oh I'm going to
ask a little bit about how you mentioned
that people consumer specifically are
very very overwhelmed when they go into
a garden center and one of the things
that I've found with retail in general
is that a lot of cases people hate
talking to a person's choose it sounds
really weird but like you go into like a
car dealership the last thing you want
is somebody hey and i hope you write
right with that type of thing is a good
they were the offical is coming to our
so yeah and one of the one of the really
cool things that incorporates making the
retail simpler with social networking is
that on the little smart tags that are
appearing on lots and lettings i know i
know my family we just reprinted all of
our tags so that they have a little
smart tag insignia on them so that
people anybody who has a smartphone can
just snap an image of it and then it
automatically takes them to our website
and give them all the information that
they would need to know about that plan
so like even if they lose the tag or
something they can still just find that
link immediately tara has all the
information that they need right that's
all right I mean we're going to do
something similar with the perfect home
garden line next year we couldn't get we
get going get it all pulled together
this spring is released to getting on
the tag and so forth restart which is
put in our acting Iran book we're gonna
start doing it next year and you're
absolutely right us because we for
almost any product anymore you do the
research online first for something to
trim some money or for something that
you're really not all that knowledgeable
are familiar with when we all do that
with such as you guys with us old folks
do the same thing because it's like it's
all out there it's accessible but but
you're absolutely reckons you don't want
to walk into a store sounding stupid are
feeling stupid or you don't know what
questions
we don't want them ourselves but
actually so you do all your research
first additionally I feel like that
would be a great way for consumers to
communicate directly with with the
companies themselves because if they're
I could go on and like review this plant
basically well I did got this plant and
I planted it in this environment and it
did very poorly or so and so it could be
a great great venue for feedback right
with the with the wave campaign we had
growing we started a wave fan club and
it would try to do some of what exactly
what you're talking about we don't we
have maybe a thousand people signed up
and they get regular email blasts from
us but we also hear back to as well and
will also end wave is on facebook and we
have someone in the office who literally
maintains it every day and she's
communicating back and forth with people
posts and then people are posting back
and forth to each other to as well son
just communicating back to us the
company but they're also communicating
with each other what works what doesn't
work I had this experience was great I
had this experience it was lousy I tried
this and he kind of create a you know
literally nylon community that way so
but it is a great way of getting that
direct feedback from the consumer how do
you think that relates to say
like
um I think it has had I think it can
have an influence in the sense that if
consumers become more comfortable with
the product or they had good success
with it or they read from somebody else
who's like them that they had good
success with it that's a much better
testimonial than me from ball telling
them that they're going to have a great
day no success with it so I think I
thought I think it can have a positive
influence on it that the challenge is
can you get enough people you know
communicating back and forth so that
better collectively you could have an
impact on sales so it's trying to build
that community I hate don't use you know
the cliches the Turner's but that's
that's normally what you try to do is
build the communities large enough so
that you have that kind of influence as
well as get feedback back to what's well
remember it was not just pick on way
which is today on the Petrelli petunia
but it's the you might just take nothing
in a row yeah you know if you might at
some point it's like we're gonna say a
moment yeah we are a little quick back
on the first of the wave is a trade name
brand name consumer brand name for a
trailing petunia that we produced we
created about 15 years ago now and it
was the one private one item that we
decided to try to market to directly to
the consumer by putting a retailer or a
Superbrand to it wait and worked on it
worked on it year in and year out for 10
11 12 years and it's taken us that long
to finally get enough traction with it
that some people will actually come into
the store asking for a wayfinding
refining to that point or if you walk
into
a store that's selling it you might
recognize it because it's always in a
pink pot or pink small container like a
six-pack it's got the wave logo on and
so forth and it is a petunia hopefully
it's in color when you're buying but
it's also a great garden performer
because it takes the heat it comes back
after a rainstorm it fills the landscape
because it's trailing and so forth and
we in fact we have different versions of
way that have a little bit different
kinds of heaven but I'll do the same
kind of thing so it's a product that
works number one in so it's the
combination of a being of a product over
the years as well as a lot of promotion
we prepared it directly to the consumer
that's kind of built a little bit of of
recognition and so now we're playing off
of to what you're talking about really
trying to connect more directly with the
consumer through you know the various
social media things that we're doing
it's probably the one big product
consumer brand success story debris or X
because at least there's some
recognition
that's hard to do because you can think
about it particularly relates to to
flowering annuals or any seasonal type
product people come up and buy it once a
year so they're like like toothpaste you
buy every month you buy it once a year
and you know come December January you
may or may not remember how well that
product reform very last year or whether
or not you liked it or were you put and
so forth and so you're starting over
again the next year so it's a little
challenge for this industry to get
consumers to come back time and time
again s up with a lot of effort into it
with a product that takes so much money
to put in to get it to that status like
where does where does it start to become
profitable when you hit big volumes yeah
yeah yep to some degree yes yes that's
right yeah and with with a product like
way for example because it has been a
success we're looking at products that
are used similarly in the garden and not
playing not giving the wave name but but
trying to attach them to the
identification of waivers is a plant
that's going to perform the same same
kinds of things other kinds of things
something but it does take a lot of
effort you really have to decide up
front how much you want to invest in
product promotion and so forth assuming
that you're going to build the volume to
be able to pay for it that's a big
challenge
what else do you find that like the
additional processing that you might
have to do for like making plants easier
to little i can get down on their hands
and knees like we have the best can like
almost like that in the way of like
goals and become more sustainable
because i actually put more energy
source
maybe what will we refine what for for
the last several years what we've been
talking about is consumers that move
from gardeners to decorators in other
words what they like is to build it by
fully finished fully in color plants
that can come home put into a container
with a single product in a container or
a mexican't product in the container and
have that instant color and have I don't
know you know half dozen pots around the
patio or around the artist so forth
rather than planting the the beds have
been patient's and so forth with a prior
generation did but it's more than just
decorating I think I think I think
there's an interest in people wanting to
do more to beautify their home and
they're in the yard is an extension of
the home anymore these days in which you
can see through proliferation of all
help her furniture and grills and
heaters and outdoor plasma TVs that you
can buy and it gets crazy after a while
but it is an extension of the home as it
relates to things like sustainable care
I think for the average consumer the
biggest thing they're probably concerned
about is am I wondering too little or
water too much like really you let us
look just like we're any business that
us to like make these
like they have to help me putting in
more like energy remember that like they
used to like to like me yeah it's that
the challenge seriousness is the size
and the condition that you want the
product to be on the shelf at retail
that's that's what the challenge comes
in is between the supplier and the
retailer you know how big do you want
the plants at retail do you want you
know a few plans to occupy a lot of
space do you want to sell a lot of
smaller plants and so forth but that's
that's where the challenge comes into
we're trying to figure out what the
consumer wants that you can provide them
the product at the stage that it's at to
me that the immediate gratification on
that same topic don't you feel like
there's kind of a contradiction between
growing plants that are programmable so
that a grower can produce 200,000 of
them for one particular weekend and they
all have to be exactly uniform that
computer could grade that the uniform
versus this general trend that you seem
to illustrate at the beginning that it
was all sustainability eco-minded he go
you know home gardening that type of
very situational non-uniform condition
and just non-uniform demands it seems to
me like that other economies are
contradiction with each other very
contradictory I agree I completely agree
with it yes yes and I you really we
don't know how the industry will
continue to evolve you know if we had
really predicting obviously we don't be
millionaires 111 thought it's just like
bowlin thought is is as it relates to
the products that people ask the growers
field they absolutely have to program a
section just what you described guess
the plant is typically an annual if you
think about the volume that they have to
produce a couple hundred thousand of
that all our kickball finish you very
uniformly at the same time which is yell
deal the ultimate growers challenge and
so forth but that's for that product
that is the how do you get subscribe
this it's that that basic plant product
that the mass consumer is going to vodka
to you the opportunity recalled or
whatever it is exit exactly
that on the one hand was I guess where
I'm headed is is is with that kind of
product we're getting to a level of I
don't know what you call it whether it's
that sophistication accessory but a
level of programming of people buying
volume that they're so accustomed to it
that they wanted instantly because they
can't repeat it success with it so they
know exactly what they want they know
exactly how they wanted to perform so it
needs to look a certain way in store
otherwise they're not going to buy it
because they already have an expectation
whereas you go to the 50 on the other
end of the spectrum which is some of
them is more environment thinking and so
forth sustained well thank you so on
we're not anywhere near that level of
experiences so if we probably have a
different set of expectations it's all
relatively new to us this has been a
production of Cornell University on the
web at cornell edu